I am taking the Michael pole and the biotoxin binder, as you suggested, the instructions
for your office said to take it about half hour away from food in the afternoon. How far away
from supplements should I take it? Since it has charcoal in it too. You're probably a better off
keeping it at least an hour away from supplements. And it would be better if you kept it an hour
away from food. So you just have to be reasonable. But if you can find that time, you know, I have
some patients that were like, they won't eat, you know, two hours before they go to bed and then
they'll take these right before they go to bed. That's something doable too. You've got to find
what's doable in your life. Some people it's more difficult because they're working full time and
it's trying to find a time to take different things and they have to kind of figure it out from themselves.
It's best if you could take those two supplements, any binders, it'd be best if you could take it
an hour away from food or supplements on either side. But then you're that's a two hour window
that you're not eating if you're able to tolerate that.